[Music]
the Boeing saga this past year is an
example of how not to handle a crisis a
relatively small design issue that
exploded into massive catastrophe they
did not build in margin for human error
this brand-new plane crashed twice in
the span of about five months how could
this possibly happen how long is this
plane going to be grounded boeing says
there's a fix when is it coming boeing
was once held up to be the gold standard
of engineering excellence and today it
has lost a lot of credibility the 737
max scandal will change aviation history
like no other event in the past five or
six decades until relatively recently
Boeing's reputation among pilots and
passengers was second to none today that
faith has been significantly shaken as
America's aviation giant continues to
reel from the fallout of two devastating
crashes that killed 346 people the max
crisis has severely crippled the
nation's biggest exporter exposed
critical flaws in the relationship
between the FAA and the businesses it
regulates and raised serious questions
how was this able to happen who is to
blame and what does this mean for the
future of the aviation industry
in late 2018 things were going pretty
well for Boeing before the first crash
Boeing thought of the max as a cash cow
that would keep on producing they were
just breaking all sorts of records for
revenue and airplane deliveries a global
boom and air travel and helped the
company earn record profits which drove
its stock price to new heights problem
prior to the crash for Boeing was that
Boeing couldn't make the max fast enough
we wrote about how Boeing was running
out of parking spots for the max the max
is the latest iteration of Boeing 737
aircraft which first entered commercial
service in 1968 it's kind of a workhorse
of Boeing's fleets if you've kind of
done any kind of medium length travel
domestically you've almost definitely
flown on a 737 as times changed so did
the 737 over the years boeing has
updated the jet dozens of times all the
while maintaining the original airframe
and this system worked well for boeing
the 737 is the most successful
commercial airplane ever made in 2017
fifty years after the first 737 took off
boeing was following a long-established
playbook when it delivered one of the
first 737 max eights to a budget
indonesian airline called line air
indonesia passenger plane crashing into
the sea minutes after takeoff 189 people
on board on October 29th 2018 a Boeing
737 max 8 jet crashed into the Java Sea
killing everyone on board there are a
bunch of questions that immediately come
up a brand new plane went into
commercial service about a year before
crashed that's unusual what could have
happened could there have been pilot
error was there a maintenance issue some
of the most important reporting to come
out after the crash was a story about an
obscure piece of software we were
obviously trying to understand things
about this airplane and the systems on
the airplane and so I went to a a VA
ssin safety conference one of the people
we talked to was a pretty senior Bo
executive and he acknowledged that they
never told pilots about the system and
essentially what's the big deal
boeing at the time argued that pilots
didn't need to know about the existence
of the automated flight control system
whose name the public would eventually
learn was em Cass well how can that be
how can there be something on the plane
not only the pilots didn't fully
understand and weren't trained on but
also just didn't know that it existed
after the first crash I think we still
didn't yet realize how big the story
would become the origin of the Mac
scandal has its roots in the rivalry
between Airbus and Boeing ever since the
1990s the two companies have been locked
in competition by the 2010s the
commercial aviation market was
essentially a stable duopoly with each
company controlling roughly half of the
market at the heart of this rivalry has
long been each company's flagship
commercial passenger plane for Boeing
that aircraft is the 737 for Airbus it's
the a320 in 2010 Airbus shook up the
market when it announced the a320neo an
updated version of the a320 aircraft
line neo planes wouldn't just be updated
versions of a familiar aircraft they
would also be cheaper to run fuel
efficiency is a touchstone of anything
that airlines do I mean if you talk
about bean counters and penny-pinchers
airlines are the ultimate in those areas
it's time to think
max Boeing did not design a completely
new plane from the ground up because it
would have taken too long to make the
max Boeing took the existing 737
airframe and paired it with a new more
powerful engine but doing that change
the planes aerodynamics one effect was
that in rare flying conditions the
aircraft's nose would pitch up this is
where the M cast software came in it was
designed to automatically push the
plane's nose down one former Boeing
engineer who didn't work on the max
characterized the software or fixed as a
band-aid we've been learning for the
last year how the band-aid wasn't as
strong as well we needed it to be
on March 10th 2019 a second crash this
time in Ethiopia all 157 people on board
were killed I heard about the second
crash when on Sunday morning I woke up
and kind of rolled over and looked at my
phone I got a text from an airline
official and it simply read max
eight I thought how could this be
another one from the moment that the
second crash happened we've really
thought or written about almost nothing
else plane crashes in general are pretty
rare plane crash within five months of
each other is pretty stunning this is
unparalleled in the modern commercial
aviation it doesn't happen a day after
the crash in an unprecedented move China
grounded the max other nations quickly
followed China grounding the planes
before the FAA had done that was a huge
deal and it came as a huge surprise to
all of us historically speaking the FAA
has always been the deleter that all the
other countries followed this was the
first time in aviation history that any
nations regulatory body had overruled
the FAA an emergency order of
prohibition to ground all flights of the
737 max eight two days later the FAA
relented and decided to ground the max
this marked the beginning of the
agency's troubles as the max crisis
brought the regulator under increased
scrutiny
in April Boeing began to face the
financial consequences of the scandal
[Music]
news then emerged the Boeing hadn't
informed the FAA that a warning system
that could help pilots diagnose an EM
cast malfunction
wasn't working as intended Boeing's lack
of transparency about M casts was
highlighted yet again when a recording
emerged of a meeting the story was based
partially on a recording made about a
month after the first crash when a group
of Boeing executives met with the
American Airlines pilot Union in the
tape
the pilots confront the executives
saying they were not told enough about
the plane a little bit too much
information for him to understand and
then in July it was revealed that after
the first crash the FAA had done its own
internal risk analysis of a potential
second crash their analysis showed that
if the FAA and Boeing didn't do anything
and just kept the planes operating as
they had been there would be 15 crashes
over some two decades that would make
the 737 max the most dangerous jet
airliner ever developed in the modern
world what was going on inside Boeing
what was going on inside FAA did anyone
discuss grounding to plane after the
first crash a lot of questions have been
raised about what the FAA role was
whether the agency was really doing its
job in overseeing the design and
production of the max the FAA delegates
Boeing employees to do some of that
oversight itself and I think some people
have questions whether that has gone too
far you know whether it's sort of the
fox guarding the hen house
[Music]
we set out to pinpoint the root cause of
how Boeing created a plane that crashes
we really tried to get to the heart of
how they came to these decisions why
didn't they use two sensors they only
use one sensor and that is sort of a
violation of basic engineering at the
root of it
Boeing made an incredibly flawed
assumption but they failed to recognize
badly that all these other emergency
signals would be confusing would make it
very very difficult for a crew to do the
right thing in a fast enough way despite
the intense scrutiny surrounding the max
at that time Boeing wasn't especially
forthcoming with information about the
plane I spent much of the summer
knocking out a lot of doors in the
Seattle area trying to find Boeing and
FA people who would help us understand
how all this happened
people would politely say no close the
door some times it was more of a door
being slammed in our face we went to I
think it was something like 200 houses
you know drove 500 miles it was really
difficult to get people to agree to talk
with us that fall Boeing CEO Dennis
Muhlenberg appeared before Congress
where he was sharply criticized by
senators we need to figure out exactly
what happened we're not quite sure what
mr. Fortner meant by that exchange I
think it was widely thought that he did
not perform well in those hearings
survived two days of really tough
questioning but he was brutally wounded
in conjunction with those hearings he
sat down with family members in the
closed-door meeting and they sat there
with large posters with photos of their
webbed ones and one case a family member
brought photos just of the coffins of
his wife and his mother-in-law and his
three children and he lost and he told
the Boeing officials including Dennis
Muhlenberg that he didn't feel they
deserved to see his family members faces
in December the company finally said we
can't keep making these planes we're
going to have to shut down our factory
and that has a huge ripple effect
throughout the supply chain and I think
all of the relatively rosy projections
that Dennis Muhlenberg had been making
throughout the year finally came to a
head and the board said enough is enough
less than a month later Muhlenberg was
fired it wasn't surprising when
Muhlenberg was pushed out it was more
surprising that it took the board as
long as it did to push Miller out he was
invisible you know a question that came
up a lot was where is Dennis in the new
year Boeing has continued to grapple
with the fallout from the Mac scandal
the end of which doesn't seem to be
anywhere in sight On January 10th Boeing
released a batch of internal
communications
they showed Boeing employees talking
about tricking regulators and say some
really unflattering things about the
regulators that they were dealing with
it gives you a real glimpse into culture
inside Boeing it was these internal
messages that likely led to Boeing's
hand being forced to reverse their
long-held stance that pilots didn't need
simulator training that is a stunning
development we had been running about
how going back nearly a decade Boeing
had designed the Macs from the start to
not require additional simulator
training for pilots flight simulators
are highly specialized machines built to
train pilots on the ground one of the
Max's biggest selling points touted by
Boeing from the beginning was that the
pilots who knew earlier 737 models like
the 737ng wouldn't need much more
training to pilot the Macs for years
Boeing assured pilots airlines and
regulators that
pilots who knew the ng could easily fly
the max after just a few hours of
training on an iPad requiring pilots to
go through simulator training before
flying the max sort of raises questions
about the fundamental you know value
proposition of the max you know what is
the value of the max since March 8th of
2019 Boeing's market value has dropped
close to one hundred and twelve billion
dollars there is an ongoing criminal
investigation by the Justice Department
there is a civil investigation by the
Securities and Exchange Commission it is
also the subject of inquiries by the
congressional lawmakers it is also being
looked at by the Department of
Transportation and the FAA the plane is
still on the ground perhaps the most
important of all 346 people died the Mac
saga shows that there's something that
needs to be reassessed in that whole
system it's time to take a breath and
let's think about the downsides of
automation how it can confuse pilots how
it can introduce unexpected consequences
and new hazards so we're looking at a
new world where other regulators will be
much more assertive and will take a much
greater role in approving aircraft even
if they're u.s. aircraft in an email to
the Wall Street Journal Boeing said the
development to the MCATs portion of the
software is complete however the entire
software package is going through the
system safety analysis and then will be
presented to the FAA for approval boeing
said it expects the Mac's to be cleared
to be back in the air this summer